Traductor: Daniel Moore
Revisor: Emma Gon
La pérdida de la visión periférica
es una afección que
disminuye el campo visual.
Según las ciencias médicas oftalmológicas,
está asociada a una retinitis pigmentaria,
a una retinopatía diabética,
o a un glaucoma.
Por supuesto que yo no soy médico,
pero si tuviese
que agregar algo a esa lista,
también agregaría
a la escuela tradicional.
El colegio mayormente pone el foco
en el desarrollo individual,
si bien compartimos
con otros un aula, un espacio,
una materia, un docente,
estudiamos en nuestro propio libro.
Nos exigen incorporar información
para ser evaluados individualmente,
y a partir de esas evaluaciones,
anotarlas en nuestra libreta personal.
Convivimos y aprendemos,
en un espacio de materias individuales,
matemáticas, física, historia, lengua,
y sufrimos generalmente el egoísmo
de los docentes que nos dicen:
"Mi materia es la más importante".
Cuando llegamos a
la facultad, eso no cambia.
Generalmente, somos estimulados
con estímulos, que son
muy pocos colaborativos,
y vamos siempre
en búsqueda del éxito personal.
Cuando terminé la facultad,
me fui a estudiar a EE. UU.,
a Irlanda y España.
Quería aprender todos
los métodos actualizados,
para aplicar en mi trabajo,
pero también,
tener mayores ventajas
comparativas al momento
de ir por la búsqueda de un empleo.
Durante mucho tiempo
me paré con la postura
de recibir información,
retenerla y aplicarla en mi trabajo.
Esas acciones, durante
los primeros 10 años,
me dieron muchísimos resultados.
Ese desarrollo individual,
esa adquisición de conocimientos técnicos,
y una obsesión por la organización,
me hicieron que tuviera
un gran reconocimiento profesional.
Pero todo eso tenía un propósito,
y el propósito era
que quería ser el mejor.
Un día, sonó mi celular,
era un llamado de la
Unión Argentina de Rugby.
Me estaban convocando
a una entrevista con Agustín Pichot,
excapitán de los Pumas y máximo referente
del plan de alto rendimiento.
Cuando tuve esa reunión,
Agustín fue concreto,
me dijo: "Vas a entrenar a los Pumas,
pero necesitamos dos cosas:
mejorar la organización y que más personas
aprendan lo que vos sabés".
Entrenar a los Pumas era mi sueño,
y era para lo que me había
preparado toda la vida,
pero ¿por qué tenía
que compartir mi conocimiento?
¿Por qué tenía que colaborar con los demás
para que sean mejores?
Me había costado mucho aprender,
había invertido mucho dinero,
y tal vez, si más personas
aprendían lo que yo sabía,
el día de mañana
me podían reemplazar por ellos.
Al poco tiempo ingresó al plan,
como asesor, Graham Henry.
Graham Henry fue el entrenador,
y uno de los precursores
de un cambio cultural en los All Blacks,
el equipo nacional
de rugby de Nueva Zelanda.
Ese cambio los llevó,
a ganar el campeonato del mundo
luego de 24 años de frustraciones,
y repetirlo al mundial siguiente.
Graham, en una de las
primeras reuniones que tuve con él
me dijo: "Los estuve viendo trabajar,
son muy buenos en lo que hacen,
pero si lo que Uds. saben
queda solamente retenido
en este equipo y en este staff,
no sirve para nada".
No estaban buscando que
los entrenamientos sean tan buenos,
ni tampoco lograr un resultado épico,
lo que querían crear, era un sistema.
Había llegado el momento,
después de que entendí la idea,
de cambiar mi foco,
de ser alguien que recibía información
y la retenía para beneficio personal,
pasar a alguien que recibía
información y la derramaba
para el crecimiento del deporte.
En definitiva, yo soy profesor
de educación física
y la raíz de ese título es la docencia.
Simbólicamente
me regalaron un par de lentes
y me dijeron: "Te toca
hacer una tarea muy difícil,
vas a tener que ir
y ver cómo reaccionan,
y cuáles son las conductas de las personas
que trabajan en una organización.
Por lo tanto, cuando vayas,
ponete estos anteojos,
te van a permitir mejorar tu campo visual,
y a su vez detectar
el déficit de visión periférica
que tienen la mayoría de las personas".
Me puse esos anteojos
y emprendí el camino,
¿qué es lo que veo, cuando voy
por distintas organizaciones
en el país viendo lo que pasa?
Que si a las personas nos dejan
organizarnos de manera espontánea,
actuamos con las mismas conductas
que la escuela tradicional.
Compartimos un momento,
compartimos un espacio,
pero somos poco colaborativos,
tenemos tendencia a agruparnos por islas,
ponemos nuestros intereses personales
por encima de los demás,
y siempre queremos sobresalir del resto.
El deporte no es la excepción.
¿Cuántos clubes creen que hay
adentro de un mismo club?
Tantos clubes como entrenadores haya.
Los entrenadores, por criterio personal,
o por intereses, desarrollan
su propio método de entrenamiento.
Eligen su propio modelo de juego
y establecen sus propias
normas disciplinarias,
hacen de su equipo su propio club.
Y cuando los chicos pasan de categoría
o cambian de categoría,
también cambian de club,
se van al club del nuevo entrenador.
Lo bueno es que por lo menos
mantienen la misma camiseta
que representa a la institución.
Entonces, lo que en un año
y con un entrenador estaba bien,
al año siguiente está mal.
Lo que un entrenador
estimulaba, el otro prohíbe.
Si a un entrenador le gustan
los sistemas ofensivos,
al otro le gustan los sistemas defensivos.
Tal vez, mientras yo estoy diciendo esto
cada uno piense y diga, "Pero Martín,
vos nos estás diciendo entonces
que la diversidad no es buena".
No, no estoy diciendo eso.
La diversidad es muy buena,
y la diversidad es lo mejor
que nos puede pasar,
para poder aprender.
La diversidad es buena,
siempre y cuando esté organizada,
si no la heterogeneidad
que genera esa diversidad,
del único modo que agrega valor,
es si está en función del objetivo
pedagógico de la institución,
y no del capricho de un entrenador,
de su ignorancia o de sus intereses.
Otra cosa que le pasa
a las organizaciones
es contar entre sus filas
con aquellos que dicen:
"Este, este qué me va a enseñar,
si hace veinte años que hago esto,
¿qué me puede enseñar?".
Y ni hablar de aquellas
organizaciones que cuentan
con personas que retienen su conocimiento,
que no están dispuestos
a entregarlo, tal como hacía yo.
Esa era mi conducta.
Y no entregamos ese conocimiento,
porque eso es lo que nos da poder.
Eso es lo que nos hace,
o creemos, que nos hace valiosos.
Pero si a eso le sumamos
que trabajamos de manera aislada
y compitiendo entre nosotros,
esas organizaciones, no tienen
ninguna posibilidad de evolucionar.
La mezquindad de conocimiento genera
una pobreza institucional enorme.
Una vez un amigo que anda por acá
me dijo: "Si querés aprender
mucho sobre un tema,
andá a hablar con el que escribió
el libro sobre ese tema,
y a cada pregunta que vos le hagas,
te va a dar respuestas detalladas,
se va a tomar el tiempo
para poder contestarte,
y se va a asegurar,
que en el momento que termine
la reunión, vos hayas aprendido.
Pero si hablás con quien leyó el libro,
probablemente no te diga
ni dónde lo compró,
o quiere ser el único en realidad
que conoce ese contenido".
Eso es algo que habitualmente sucede
y esa mezquindad de conocimiento
genera que también
las organizaciones estén presas
de lo que nosotros llamamos
la teoría del superhéroe.
Entonces cuando la organización no está
pasando un buen momento y le va mal,
vamos a buscar a alguien
que nos pueda salvar.
Entonces contratamos a Superman.
Viene Superman y si no tiene resultados,
le damos una patada,
le arrancamos la capa
y lo tiramos a la hoguera.
Total, ahora vamos en búsqueda de Batman,
y si Batman no tiene resultados,
también le quitamos el antifaz
Y eso sucede tantas veces,
como sea necesario,
hasta que encontremos
aquella persona que nos dé éxito.
Cuando eso sucede
le otorgamos un poder mesiánico,
por habernos permitido
ganar un campeonato,
pero no nos damos cuenta
que siempre hay una organización
de mucho mayor poder
económico que la nuestra,
entonces como también está
en búsqueda de un superhéroe,
se lo lleva.
Y ahí quedamos de nuevo en la organización
tratando de encontrar un salvador
al que vamos a tirar a la hoguera,
o al que vamos a volver a endiosar.
Las instituciones pierden muchísimo
dinero con las teorías de los superhéroes,
y generalmente o mayormente,
nunca dan resultado.
La manera de poder contrarrestar
estas conductas personalistas
que yo les acabo de describir
es creando sistemas educativos.
Las organizaciones deportivas,
empresariales, políticas,
que logran tener resultados por más
tiempo, o que crecen año tras año,
son aquellas que
trascienden a las personas.
Desde que me puse esos anteojos,
recorrí la Argentina
a lo largo y a lo ancho,
en tres deportes distintos:
rugby, fútbol y básquet,
y mi concepto de qué es ser el mejor
cambió por completo.
Antes yo pensaba que los mejores
eran los que más sabían.
Hoy creo que los mejores
son quienes desarrollan
sistemas educativos de colaboración.
Hay que tener dos voluntades
para poder ser parte de un sistema.
La voluntad de aprender sabiendo
que es mucho más lo que ignoramos
que lo que sabemos, por lo tanto
en cualquier momento,
o de cualquier persona, podemos aprender.
Y la voluntad de
compartir el conocimiento.
La voluntad de compartir el conocimiento
permite que cualquier organización
pueda extraer de nuestra cabeza
todo lo que nosotros sabemos,
y lo pueda redactar en un
documento vivo que se transforma
en un activo institucional,
y a partir de eso,
en la organización
ya no importa quién sabe más.
Lo que importa es que el sistema sabe más.
Por lo tanto, si la institución
tiene que ir a buscar
a un superhéroe,
no importa si gana o pierde,
no importa si se lo llevan
o se queda por un tiempo determinado.
Si abre su cabeza y nos permite
que su conocimiento quede redactado
en ese documento, ya habrá
enriquecido al sistema.
No traje 4000 pares de lentes
para poder compartir con Uds.,
pero a través de esta charla,
lo que quiero es colaborar
para que podamos ampliar
nuestra visión periférica,
y tal vez, podamos dejar de pensar
que nos va a salvar un superhéroe,
un deportista, un entrenador,
un ministro de economía o un presidente.
Yo me comprometí a desarrollar
sistemas y hacer que se cumplan.
Los invito a que cada uno de nosotros
tengamos la voluntad de enriquecer
los sistemas de los que somos parte,
y exijamos que se respeten.
Tal vez así podamos lograr
que las instituciones crezcan
y que nuestro país no tenga
que empezar de cero todos los días.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)